Hello and welcome to this video on jump animations.
In this video we are going to be using the state machine to create a jump animation loop.
That's going to consist of three animations.
So it's going to consist of start jump, a falling loop, and a landing animation.
So let's go back into the project now.
So the first thing we're going to want to do is open back up our animation blueprint.
Now in order to trigger this animation we need to know if the character is in the air.
So this would cover either if it was falling or jumping.
And we're going to do that on the event blueprint update animation.
Now the first thing I'm going to do is I'm going to add in the sequence at the beginning.
And I can do that by holding down the S key and left clicking on the background.
I'm just going to connect that up here.
This is just so I can keep things tidy really.
And here on the then1 output pin, what I'm going to do is I'm going to grab another reference to the character movement.
So I'll just copy this and paste this here.
Because we're going to use the character movement component again.
Because that's going to tell us if we are in the air.
There's a function which allows us to figure this out.
You drag off and you type in isFalling.
And you'll see that this function will detect if you are falling.
And it's going to return a boolean value for true if you're falling and false if you're not falling.
So I will right-hand click on this and promote this to a variable.
And I'm going to call this variable isFalling.
And connect that up.
All this is going to do each time the animation is updated,
is just going to check the character movement, see if we're falling and save that to a variable.
As I mentioned before, this is going to run multiple animations.
And we're going to use the state machine to achieve this.
So I'm going to jump back into our locomotion state machine.
And as you can see, at the moment, we only have idle to run.
Now, I want to add three more states.
And I'm going to do that by just coming over to my asset library here.
And I'm going to search for jump.
And I'll find mm underscore jump, drag that in.
You can see it's going to automatically create a state that is going to play the mm underscore jump animation.
It's a nice quick way to make a state.
I could rename it, but I'm not going to worry about that now.
The next one I want, if I type in full, is the mm underscore full loop.
Drag that in, place that over here.
And the final one I want is land.
And I'm going to drag that in down the bottom here.
Now, in order for us to use any of these, we are going to have to connect them up.
So if I come from the idle to run, drag over and connect that up,
it's going to create me a transition between these two states.
Do that.
And I am going to create another transition from the jump to the full loop.
The last one from the full loop to the land loop.
And the final one back to the idle to run.
Now this is the first time we've come across transitions.
The transition is going to be a gate which, when the condition is true,
it will move you into the other state or animation with a little bit of a blend in between.
So at the moment, if I was to click on the idle to run animation,
you can see here I have a boolean input with a can enter transition.
Now we have nothing plugged into this.
We want to plug in some kind of condition to see if we can enter this transition.
And what we're going to do for that is we're just going to grab the isFalling variable that we populated
and place that on top of it.
So if I jump back,
so what this is going to mean is we're going to start in the idle to run.
And as soon as it's detected that we're falling,
it's going to move down this transition to the mm underscore jump and play that animation.
Now we also want to move out of this transition into the m underscore m full loop.
So if I double click on this transition and to enter this transition,
I want to wait until the animation that we've just played is almost finished.
So how I'm going to do that is I'm going to right-hand click
and I am going to search for remain.
And you'll see that we have an option of time remaining and time remaining ratio.
I'm going to use the time remaining ratio
and I'm going to drag out and I'm going to do is less than and have 0.1
less than 0.1. So right at the end of the animation.
Now I'm going to connect that up.
This means when the animation is almost over, you can enter the transition into the next section.
Now we're in the full loop.
I want to leave the full loop when we're no longer falling.
So it's going to remain in here until we hit the ground.
And so I'm going to jump into this transition here.
From here, again, I'm going to grab the is falling.
However, this time I'm just going to get it because I want to do this one on the floor.
So I want to add a boolean for not.
A not boolean and I want to plug that in.
So all this is going to do is it's going to check that we are no longer falling.
Then it will allow us to enter the next state.
Finally, for our last transition, I'm going to jump in.
We are just going to kick this arm.
So this means we will automatically be able to enter the other transition.
So we're going to do this because this animation is so short
that just the blend in and the blend out time is going to be enough for us.
Hit compile.
And now if I come back into the game and I play,
you're going to see that we hit something a little bit odd.
If I jump, suddenly at a small point, I shrink down to almost nothing.
Now this is an oddity of the land animation.
So let's go back to the stage tree.
If I go into the mm underscore land.
Now the odd thing about the land animation is this is an additive animation.
So it is actually very small because it only contains the data
that would need to be added to another animation
in order to imitate the rebound on the floor.
So therefore, if we play this as a simple animation,
it's going to shrink the character down to that small additive data.
Now, in order to fix this, what I'm going to do is
I am going to disconnect the result pin here.
And I'm going to search for a apply additive.
I'm going to plug this into our output pin.
I'm going to plug the mm underscore land into the additive.
Now I need a base animation at this point to play.
So we're going to use the blend space that we created.
So I'm going to find the my blend space walk run,
drag that in, and then plug that into the base.
And again, in order to get this to work, we need to add the speed in.
And so what this is going to do is it's going to go back to our walk cycle and play that
because we've hit the ground.
And it's just going to add in the small rebound additive data in here
so we can see that rebound.
If we now compile, save, jump back into the mat and play,
you should see that this is a pretty realistic run and jump.
In the next video, we're going to look at how we can trigger an animation
to be played from a keyboard input.